[Music]
we're on 104 show tour and
it's pretty intense all the time but
this isn't a story about a famous
musician
this is a story about a guy growing up
if there was one word we could use to
describe shawn mendes it would be
wonderful yes the canadian heartthrob
officially dropped his highly
anticipated netflix documentary in
wonder
and it's safe to say the mendez army
won't be disappointed
from intimate details about his
relationship with camila cabello
to the process behind his new album
wonder we're breaking down
everything we learned about the
grammy-nominated artists and his journey
to self-discovery this is what it's like
filming a documentary
here we go so at the beginning of the
film we go right into how sean
began his rise to fame on vine and how
he transitioned from playing music in
his bedroom to commanding a fully packed
electric arena on his 2019 tour
i think i heard a great big world say
something
for the first time and was like wow
that's a really great song
googled it and one of the first search
results was
shawn's cover of the song
[Music]
and i was just taken aback of it it was
like this is really incredible
reached out and we facetimed sean and
his mom
immediately sean just starts grilling us
with questions
about how the music business works why
he might need a manager
and i just said to them i was honest i
was like look i don't know everything
but i'm gonna
sit here and spend every minute of my
time figuring it out with you
i would always say to him i need to get
a band because
i'm gonna sound bad on my own he's like
no man just get on the stage just you in
the guitar
having the confidence was all based off
of those first couple years of
performing with just a guitar
[Music]
i went from a small bedroom and pick
ring to playing in front of a few
thousand people in a couple years
[Applause]
now i feel like the moment in the dark
that everyone will be talking about was
the intimate look at his relationship
with girlfriend camila cabello
yes we finally got more details on how
their close friendship
turned into the deep romantic connection
they have today
okay super cozy
[Music]
i guess it must have been about four or
five years ago we were backstage at this
taylor swift show
i went to his dressing room to say hi
and we like started writing this song
and then after that we like spent a lot
of time with each other because we had
this song together and we like did a
whole jingle ball tour together
and that's really when the
saga started
i really liked him
i guess he liked me but
i don't really know
although we get to see a lot of the
glitz and glamour of being an
international pop star
shawn does take us back to his apartment
in toronto and
his family home in pickering ontario and
to be honest
it just shows how normal the 22 year old
really is
mom i feel like i kind of live here
again he only ever comes here to eat
not true yes you do what is this every
time you walk in you're hungry
look at this look at the sweater camilla
oh my god
my girlfriend do you know about her no i
don't sean
you need more money than all of us do
you have anything here to eat for free
oh yeah
come here hey buddy
but throughout the film shawn does
wonder if
fans will ever view him as that normal
guy
oh if i tell the world that i'm just a
normal human are they going to stop like
coming to the shows and listening to the
music and like
is all the is all the craziness going to
stop and then
you're like well maybe i shouldn't tell
them maybe i should keep the trick up
maybe i should
pretend that i'm superman for a little
bit longer now despite all of the
amazing scenes of fans dancing and sean
singing his heart out on stage
we do get to see more of a vulnerable
side of the in my blood performer
ahead of his sold out show at the rogers
center in toronto
sean revealed that he keeps a
manifestation journal
this was two weeks before we put roger
center on sale november 24th 2018.
i go i wrote here we go i will sell at
the rogers center
i remember i was in this condo
and on november 28th 25th 2018. and you
wrote i sold out the rest i sold
at the roger center but the most
heart-wrenching moment of the doc was
chronicled towards the end when sean had
to cancel a show in brazil
due to doctor's orders and it left him
in tears
experienced it already it wasn't like
you've never been there now
i'm serious
sorry five stops
[Music]
[Music]
however throughout all of the craziness
of his world tour
sean was also simultaneously working on
his new album
wonder due out on december 4th and
thankfully
the cameras were there to capture the
creation of his new record
teach me teach me
[Music]
so what did you think of in wonder tell
us your favorite moment from the film
in the comments below